her body was found this morning  and we have reason to believe that it's  your husband what do you think happened  to dad  he slipped and fell normally when we  rule out foul play we'll look for one or  two people who might have disliked  the victim in the case of your husband  i'm already in double figures  we were his family families always fight  it's never easy  you still don't think this was an  accident thing i had reasons to kill dad  you had reasons we can't have been the  only ones  do you have any idea how often that man  cheated on me  you know it's all a lie this whole  family  i'm always coming second with you well  to my family to my children  grace will remember what i tell her to  remember  do you think i kill dad i don't mom  open your eyes  get our story straight okay i've always  been here for you  i don't give a damn about the truth  i just care about protecting my family  you